Speaker 1: Let's go next to Dan from Oregon. Dan
from Oregon. Welcome to the David Pakman show.
What is on your mind today?
Speaker 4: Hi. Hi,
David. So I am trying to figure out where
I'm at politically right now. You know, I
was very much a backer of most of the
Democratic establishment goals, you know,
in my younger years. And I was starting to
do more and more research and look into how.
Difficult. It is really move the needle on
a lot of these big political issues with the
constant stranglehold of the. Capitalist
class. And just wondering where we're.
Conversations could go where you think we can
actually move the needle in getting people
to recognize the inherent hell we're trying to
climb over, You know, these giant changes that
need to be made when there's the big money
influence is just constantly keeping their.
Speaker 1: This is so tough. I mean, I wish there
was a simple answer, but you're basically saying
how can you circumvent the system that got us
to where we are? Without having any system,
but that system with which to do it right.
And this is this is what makes this stuff
so difficult. You accurately diagnose that
there are so many people that aren't even sort
of like aware of the top level structural and
systemic things that need to happen. You know,
I think that these things include campaign
finance, how we run elections, media. You know,
I've talked about like my big overarching issues
that affect every issue, but we're sort of limited
by using the very broken system. We have to get
people to recognize this stuff. And it is the
very same system which makes it so a lot of people
can't afford to take time off in order to go to a
protest and all these things. So, I mean, listen,
I could repeat like the same stuff I always say,
but obviously it's not working in any real way, so
I don't have an answer. And it's sort of like one
of the most critical questions, which is great.
We've identified the problems of the system and
now we need to work within that system in some
way. Like I know you can say, well, work outside
the system, right? But so how are we going to
communicate with people? We've got social media,
traditional media, print media. You can go out
and do street preaching, but we know kind of
how that works. So it is a really difficult
question and I wish I had a better answer.
Speaker 4: I realize it was a very broad question,
but, you know, I, I really value the way you put
things out there. And I just wanted to hear
your take on that. But it's something that
I'm very interested in putting some energy into
and learning more about. And yeah, just. I would
love to see. Some movement in that direction as
far as getting more people on board, It's crazy
to me that I said and talked to people that you
know. Consider the cells being on the right. Yeah.
When I. Kind of talk about the goals of what, you
know, we're trying to at socialism essentially
would would accomplish without actually seeing
socialism. They tend to jump on board real quick
and agree with me. But that's interesting.
Speaker 1: Well, as you know, Dan,
I am not a socialist, but I still
share many of the same immediate
next steps that you would identify, I'm sure.
Speaker 4: Yeah, right. Well, we all know the
corporate stranglehold is is killing us all.
Speaker 1: All right, my friend. Thank you for
bringing up this important issue. I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: Have a good day.
Speaker 1: All right. There goes Dan
from Oregon. Let's welcome back to the
program. Johnny from Boston. Johnny, welcome.
You're going to be watching C PAC at all.
Oh, boy. No, you're not watching
it. Okay, Fair. All right, good.
Speaker 5: I have other things to watch.
Speaker 1: That's fair. I totally respect that.
Speaker 5: So I wanted to ask about your interview
with Pandora's Box. I know it wasn't on the show,
but I saw it kind of on the link, actually.
Yes. To watch Pandora. How did you get connected
with her and how has the response been so?
Speaker 1: Well, my colleague John handled
making the initial contact and actually
Pandora was connected to the show,
the dish that I had a cameo on. And so I
actually think that was the connection and
the response has been pretty good. I have to
tell you. I mean, listen, the homophobes and
the anti drag and the anti-trans and everybody
in that space came up with their same predictable
responses. But a ton of people wrote to me
saying, I learned a ton about the difference
between drag performers and trans people, which
I, I was actually kind of shocked that a lot of
people didn't realize we're talking about
two different things. And just generally,
people were very positive about the interview.
Speaker 5: That's good. I loved it. I was I was
so excited. I actually recorded a podcast with
her drag sister, Aggie, down from Rochester,
and I was like, Do you know what she did? She's
doing some great she's doing God's work right now.
And especially with Have you heard about the
thing going on in Tennessee with the governor?
Speaker 1: Yeah, we covered it earlier this
week where he's doing all this anti drag
stuff. And then he was confronted
with a picture of himself in drag.
Speaker 5: Yeah. And it's it's like it's
crazy because Nashville has some amazing
drag performers. It's like I'm really worried
that it's going to put a lot of them out of
work because the bill is really draconian.
Speaker 1: It's all crazy. I mean, listen,
what I really learned from the interview
with with Pandora was there's really nothing
to be worried about in this entire
drag panic that there is. Yeah. As
if I didn't already know that. But, you know.
Speaker 5: Sure. I mean, there's nothing to it.
There's nothing to worry about.
Speaker 1: There really.
Speaker 5: Is. Exactly. And, you know, I, I
one of a one of your other colleagues earlier
talked about Jorge Santos and how you talk
about I, I call her guitar bass because I,
I'm a part time drag queen, so I have no problem
calling her by her drag name. Okay. I understand
why you didn't want to, but just letting
you know, I would. I would call her Katara,
and I will continue to call her.
Speaker 1: That's all right,
Johnny. You do You, my friend. I appreciate that.
Speaker 5: All right. Thanks, Dave. Appreciate it.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Johnny from
Boston. Always great to hear from him.